tout vient à point pour qui sait
attendre et en droit de se dire ce soir
le pdg de la régie renault monsieur
georges besse en effet aujourd'hui à l'
usine de flins il vient de remettre les
clés de contact à l'acheteur de la
500.000e supercinq vendus en une seule
année ce qui est un record que même la
205 peugeot la concurrence n'a pas battu
reportage jean-pierre métivet et michel
alik of 7 500 millièmes clé c'est vrai
c'est un exploit
un record de monter en cadence 500000 su
personnes dès la première année un
record salué par edith cresson pourtant
l'important réside est ailleurs c'était
l'une des premières manifestations
publiques de georges besse mais l'accord
de journalistes a obtenu bien peu de
précisions sur la politique de cet homme
secret
et les suppressions d'effectifs chez
renault où elles se sont passées en
douceur cette année par des départs
volontaires
est-ce que vous pensez que ce sera aussi
simple l'an prochain
obtenu la même façon je vous pose des
problèmes que quand ils arrivent
chaque moment année 85 passe très bien
chirac c'est une éventuelle des
nationalisations
parce que vous avez un problème tu
regardes le propriétaire c'est tout
c'est peu et georges besse consacrera
plus de temps aux délégués cgt qu'ils
aborderont qu'aux journalistes
est-ce qu'on français de remplacer
d'embaucher des jeunes chômeurs je le
prends très au gras
vous savez que dans l'ensemble de
renoncer en raison de l'augmentation de
la productivité due aux investissements
que nous avons faits
celui d'investissement
pourront réaliser la même production est
même plus avec moins de 80 non seulement
prochaine mais également de structure et
c'est un peu ça qu'on s'efforce de faire
sans drame sans drame c'est toute la
question posée à georges besse et à
edith cresson représentant du
propriétaire des lieux l'état qui pour
l'instant mais pas vendeur de la régie
tout ça appartient à la nation depuis de
longues années
depuis 1945 alors je pense que le moment
n'est pas venu de se poser ce genre de
questions le moment est venu par pondre
se mobiliser autour de la régie pour
aider ses succès qu l'optimisme était de
mise la régie aujourd'hui après tout ce
n'est pas si fréquent
un pavé qui va faire